[Music]  five seconds four three two one time's  up  he's coming you're grabbing the  president come up here that much longer  little you ready think is she gonna be  all right  you said she fainted in the Attic I've  never seen her so scared you're playing  the game aren't you what done the  midnight man  this is no game for kids or for  teenagers a midnight man is utterly  ruthless if your candle blows out you  must realize it in 10 seconds it doesn't  relight surround yourself with a circle  of salt for protection if any of these  rules are broken the midnight men will  manifest your worst nightmares the  midnight man doesn't like to lose you  mean he cheats I'm protected he's very  very good at it  it's the color of your blood  those are just playing with me right  just a game  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]